well going back to the 60s though the
time of change we're in the 50s everyone
was a good student and they obeyed their
parents and then i'm not sure what point
things started to unravel i think it was
Vietnam right that kind of set things
off and Kent State or now when did this
hall it was I can tell you the day
usually November was at number 1 20
second 1963 Jack Kennedy got shot and
when Jack Kennedy got shot the world
changed it's just like 911 was the same
thing people suddenly felt that the
world in which we had grown up in was
totally transformed that a new level of
danger and untrustworthiness he had
arrived and I would say that the
assassination Jack Kennedy was the 60s
60s really got rolling a few years later
in 66 and 67 before that it was still
more the 50s but it was very turbulent
time in a very exciting time and we all
thought that we're going to transform
the world and to some extent we did but
maybe the world transformed us right so
there was the civil rights moving sexual
revolution knows what is different today
because today's are there's mistrust
over the government there's the fear of
people reading our emails there's the
banks that many children you know
witness their parents homes being
foreclosed on what do you think the
difference is now it's hard to say
because in many ways there are
similarities it just feels some life
there's an underlying acceptance and
complacency even despite all those
protests that's different than the 60s
in the 60s it's felt a little realer in
the 60s it felt a little more dangerous
I happen to have had some experience for
just like a week or so as an exchange
student until in a southern college and
just being in that environment from
northern kid was really a credible sort
of experience so I'm not really a
sociologist I can't really explain why
they are same and what I different but
my goodness that was a profoundly
transformative moment and this one for
all the troubles doesn't quite feel the
same way to me
you